[Music]
as for trump's covet diagnosis
president has indeed tested positive
this is new territory the internet is
going
crazy over this overnight reporters were
sent scrambling after the trump news
broke a little before 1am
on the east coast what then did you do
they had me call in
to the overnight breaking coverage this
has potential for a lot of seismic
changes to the campaign trail
as things were breaking last night i
just picked up
a room service menu to try to keep
things straight
but it's tough i need both of you to
stand by
sam and brian cnn's brian stelter whose
wife jamie reports for ny1's morning
show
shared this text exchange they had it
began at 12
10 am fyi in case you wake up i'm doing
a live shot in the dining room
jamie responded at 307 am send me
anything good that comes your way that i
can use
cnn of course has been affected by the
virus most notably with chris cuomo
whose wife and son
also contracted covey it's definitely
took a toll on him it is a minimum
of 21 days for a lot of people it works
its way through families
all the time today more coveted cases
swept the white house as chris wallace
revealed what happened
with trump's family during the debate
the trump
family came in i'm told wearing masks
but then took them off once they sat
down in their seats
that actually violated the rules i have
a mask right here i
put a mask on it you know when i think i
need it a safety person a health person
came up to the first family when they
were seated and offered them mass in
case they didn't have them and they were
waved away
having been in cleveland does that
concern you about being in the line of
fire for coronavirus
we need multiple negative covet tests
and so i'm
confident but again everything changes
we are gonna stay six feet apart from
everybody that we have to until somebody
tells us that it is okay